okay for people who are joining this
livestream we're going to be talking
about calculus and algebra functionality
for the next version of Wolfram language
and let's get started
okay so the big picture is eleven three
was the the land of asymptotic so what's
next for vision for the next version so
the headliner is still asymptotics and
these are sin death time we had solvers
for integrate in differential equations
now it's sums and differences as well as
algebraic equations okay I don't
understand what asymptotic sold I'm
about to find out this out I guess right
these are okay alright so where should
we look
should I look at examples here what's
there there it's not there so you go to
the pay for those guys I meant to put in
a few key ones here but if you go to the
reference page it's full of examples for
each okay okay
I might should I be in version twelve
and the in the eleven three
I'm insert twelve the external do you
want to run it okay all right
my head branch build seems to have
turned white I don't know why it's odd
and there's a little suspicious what
that seems pretty white to okay okay so
exam okay I think I need to look at some
examples here okay so this is saying by
the way this is somebody should report
is there somebody from project
management or otherwise here or not
because there's a bug here the this is a
bug for John this is the new 64-bit
front-end I think so the magnification
pop-up is missing it's not missing it's
if you look at the top right corner
that's still under discussion but where
was its final resting places what's that
weird white area down there that's
showing that something there's something
wide right so that should be a scroll
right that should be a vertical scroll
it's not it's not it's not that all
right Skaar from the from the sizing oh
it's the scrollbar isn't the whole this
goal bar has to be useless let's go var
appears to report this to the
appropriate people okay okay so let's
take a look at this asymptotic sum the
sum 1 over square roots to n and then
you let n go to infinity and you want to
see what's how it scales it you know
when n goes large so I mean let me just
understand this sort of naive level I
mean so if I were just doing this boy
this is kind of confusing I don't mind
it at the top here by the way we've got
a bunch of background noise here so if I
just say some of this like so I mean
get some random harmonic number okay and
if I were to say series of that at
infinity it better be the same okay so
why is there a single function that does
this it's not quite the same it's
actually not the same it's notably not
the same I mean it's got why is the
powers I mean those are small as n goes
to infinity
that's humongous as n goes to infinity
so this ordering yeah so right okay so
serious data does not have the ability
to represent everything we need to
represent now it's it's a big project
and we were this as part of working out
what the future of that should be and so
there two aspects to it one is and in
the let's say in the univariate case you
need to have other kinds of scales to be
representable yeah okay and it's it's
it's a careful trade-off if we go to
general you can't do anything with it
but you can represent everything sure if
we go to narrow we can do a bunch of
things with it but it can't represent
many things right is this an ordinary
expression he has an ordinary expression
right now and so the ordering that you
see there comes from plus and it's done
okay okay it's an experimental functions
Steve Anka you know and so those are
things that we expect to do there you
know the other thing so this is about
generating a bunch of these series but
we've also got integrate doesn't do that
as I'm talking to create produces
something different correct no no it
does exactly like this oh because we
can't use serious data this is what I'm
saying
so we will want a container but we want
to carefully design that container it
just so happens that these scales
earlier on here are simple enough that
some order is what you expect it okay
okay but so what's the difference
between series of some and osmotic some
it it is a whole variety of methods that
will you know first of all series of
some doesn't do anything did something
just fine here oh I see I see
no so this works even when you can't
evaluate it in too close form that's the
whole point of these things yeah I
understand
but presumably you should make series of
some eventually work right that's for
our next release you'll have a whole
slew of things to discuss there okay
okay that's cool that's cool by the way
we have this meeting coming up on
generated parameters hmm because that
needs to be globally what are you doing
for generator parameters here what are
they with all the parameters well this
is the existing see right evening
parameters and it indexed them okay all
right okay fine what does none do here
like just yet what does it do so for an
indefinite integral it will not generate
the general solution with a parameter in
this case but yes sure I'm saying
Stephen leicht for current integrate
doesn't generate the see I see I see I
get it I get it there's a constant of
integration type thing yes I thought
these were necessary internal parameters
for some subs some that it was doing or
something no
so what is that so that's an indefinite
some yes fair enough okay
this is all quite quite magnificent I
mean series of difference Delta so
difference Delta of this thing should
return the original expression if you do
a an indefinite some the very definition
of that is like for indefinite integral
that if you take the derivative yeah I
get it yeah it should give back the
original thing up to constants yes
actually
there's no constant yeah the constant
goes away for when you do the rivet well
this looks this looks nice I mean I get
what this is doing I think Aston
protocol value let's take a look at that
guy
yeah this is a bug the stupid white
thing down here but then I said I don't
object to that being up there as long as
I can find it yeah so so they're two to
two cases here one is this so that case
when you want to see so how it evolves
for large time or you know high index
value mm-hmm asymptotic series for that
the other case just example below is
when you have a parameter in there
that's usually called perturbation
analysis which we already had for the
case of differential equations right so
this one's follows that pattern right
doing both nice turn off I have no
objections asymptotic solve it's gonna
deal with things which were going to be
degenerate among other things but as you
increase what is all of this it says you
can
approach the point at which you want the
expansion from different directions so
direction was an option for limits yes a
little bit general for that but whatever
what's the difference between the Y and
the X here really you view this as a you
know as a function of X shrimp saying y
is a function of X if you're not I see
but well why do you have to give the 0
there
well you shouldn't you know at homes but
you can have multiple ones you know but
but in ordinary solve there's no way you
can say variable comma 0 it doesn't mean
other thing right but you're sort of
right you're yeah
second example Steven doesn't have that
and then you get three different
solutions for different solutions right
so these are solutions that approach a
given point and and all solutions though
I mean I would have expected that I
would just do this and it works fine
yeah I wouldn't put a brace why would
you say a brace and so if I were to put
I mean if I were to do this right this
particular one doesn't have any at zero
so if you do - I get the first one I see
but if I were to do this if I were to
say solve you know x squared plus X x
squared equals x it's a bad example x
squared equals one you know X around
minus one that doesn't mean anything
does it
no no so I don't understand this I mean
it's an interesting syntax you have one
maybe if you go to the applications
examples I'm trying to understand why
didn't this work I mean that would
an interesting way to do it is to say
give me the go-ahead well the point is
that you are you know basically finding
the solution has a function of a
variable right and so you're saying
what's your starting point right the
here X is the dependent is the
independent variable just like in your
asymptotic solve X is the independent
variable Y the Y is look I mean what
you're doing is you're saying this and
then you're expanding with respect to a
basically this is the independent
variable the genuine independent
variable for this no that's that's the
defendant field is the dependent you
look why isn't Y goes to X is your
solution just like I'm okay okay sorry
you're saying independent deep I'm
getting that wrong and honestly this
will be clearer if this was written out
as you know this would be less confusing
to me if this was written out here with
this Y being an axe right and then this
X being some kind of epsilon or
something sure and I would I would
strongly encourage doing that in the
examples you mean yeah an example well I
I don't I don't think that's quite right
[Music]
in the case where epsilon goes to
infinity I also think right I mean
you're talking about moving right you
you have you have some implicitly
defined function and you're finding the
expansion of that implicitly defined
function is what you're really doing and
being able to specify is which branch
you're on yeah I get it I get it exactly
but but I'm saying to you and and the
reason that it doesn't make sense for
solve is because in this case you're
saying it's approximately zero right
in Seoul you know it's zero when I
assume you mean it's 0 and epsilon
equals zero is that right yes okay so
you're giving the case whereas here it
would be meaningless to say something
there because you either nail the value
or you don't right right so so basically
you have the solution of this constant
equation and then you are varying the
parameter around this solution right but
so so in the case where if I didn't give
a starting value there then I'm gonna
get all branches all whatever's if you
can generate it for me right yes yes and
you will get into trouble if there are
infinitely many well let's see what it
does is this good case where they're
infinitely many yeah what is it lovely
so what's it doing here well it's checks
that it's not a polynomial and during
intimated solution say it's goes into
trouble rather than just mutely saying
forget it they should say it can't solve
it I mean rather than just I think in
that case but but but the basic point
you're making here is the reason this
isn't relevant for solve so for what
functions is irrelevant
it must be relevant whenever there's an
asymptotic thing going on because why
isn't it relevant to a standard D salt
for example or is it well I guess it's
in some future state where we have more
D II's because then you get the LD break
equations in there as well yes but
really you know even for asymptotic D
solve and our salt and so on we localize
we say at what what point the
independent variable should be at and in
the cases that we can now solve there
isn't multiple solutions the German
saying is not implicit enough yeah you
think for
it's like a boundary conditions right so
it's a way of we can say that Y of zero
equals seven or something that's we just
put it in somewhat different place well
let's talk about where it should be put
here because this is like in some of our
fine minimum type functions this is sort
of a starting value but it's a little
different here yeah it's different
it truly is localized to that point yes
what do you mean by localized to that
point anything asymptotics is localized
to the point at which you develop it
around I'm saying this is developing
around the point epsilon equals zero and
around the point x equals zero that's
correct but you're automatically finding
the possible points to develop around in
a case like this that's right but the
theorem says it's problem when they're
infinitely many because our list don't
take infinitely many elements yet there
was a person at the summer school this
year who did a very interesting project
and infirm lists which hopefully we'll
get presented to you so okay
the quite reasonable stuff
right yes even if you scroll down to the
applications example the first set you
know actually written out set of
applications and samples then think
there's an illustration that makes this
somewhat clearer yeah and I'm not using
the zero syntax here okay I just want to
know what's an analogy for that zero
syntax in other words you know selecting
a solution around blah blah blah because
it's not quite an expansion point this
is the expansion point here well no
really zero zero is the expansion point
well but it's valid for all X the small
epsilon but for all X no to 0 where
epsilon goes to 0 yeah how do you
describe this right I mean it's supposed
to alternative would be to add you know
support for specifying initial condition
like things right where you would say
write epsilon of zero equals zero but
what the heck is epsilon of zero well in
the case I was looking at is X and
epsilon accessible right right so it's X
of zero X is the function X no I think
this is super confusing calling this
wine X I think it's a big mistake I
think you should come up with another
parameter name for the expansion here
because X is too often what you're
solving for but you know yes but what
you're solving
for is Y of X right you're not solving
either for Y or for X you're solving for
y of X that's the point this is sort of
returning to you function y I get it I
get it but I'm saying you're solving for
look look at the thing that's on this
right hand side here it's that variable
there that's the thing you're solving
for as a function of this variable here
mm-hmm
right okay so what do you think is a
good generic expansion variable epsilon
probably doesn't cut it because of the
infinity case and I think these should
be called you know this should be X and
X zero probably here and whatever that
parameter is called I don't know what
you want to call that you steal it
perhaps what's that G a little bit I
would prefer something different because
it's not a parameter like that it might
be e for example you know and then a
zero and then n so this is not what you
want to say here it's not Y of X look
there's no way that's because you've
replayed well but you could've right
I've done that I could have written it
out like that but you're not writing it
out like that that's what it's returning
but this is what it's solving for it's
not solving for x it's right X is your
dependent variable in my in this case
here it's solving for x you know Stephen
I was thinking that it's it's a little
weird but it might help you
so d solve when you specify for D salt
that you want to solve for y bracket X
yes comma X but it returns is y bracket
of X rule and the solution indeed okay
then we have another syntax we support
and it reports a pure function because
it pays better on the back substitution
yep
okay and
you know by the way that's a bucket if
somebody can report it that that those
two things are smooshed there yeah
that's a known issue I think you know
but but for diesel it really occurs like
that you know Y of X is really y of X I
know absolutely that's point I'm making
yeah right but but it isn't ever
occurring like that but but you are
effect you know the result if you look
at that formula that comes out in that
very first example it's exactly what we
had there it's just it's just not saying
it's so that's not but you don't need to
I mean this is like and when we do you
could say Y of X in the case of an
ordinary salt you know you could solve
say I mean I don't assign you we don't
give the implicit dependence on
parameters normally the parents of
parameters is not in the X it is in the
X does not depend on the parameter
epsilon epsilon is merely the solution
that depends on the parameter epsilon so
implicitly X actually depends on epsilon
if it's going to satisfy that equation X
actually depends on Appstore as you
change epsilon you change the solution
for X yeah exactly right and that's what
I understand but I'm saying what okay
look what I strongly suggest here is I
think everything works all you do is you
say X comma X zero except I would first
of all do the case with X here without
discussing X zero I would first say it
computes as no approximations to
solutions for X as a function
II to order whatever fine we can change
that okay so now this one um so actually
this is a weird case because this is
sort of almost the transpose of what I
would expect right okay what does a
multivariate series look like there what
does a usual multivariate series about
when I do multivariate series about a
point blah blah blah
so these guys we can report today
technology allows us to have up to two
to two to multivariate puso series yeah
in I'm sorry four series you're saying
no for this guy I say series of
something like you know e to the minus x
squared plus y squared and then I say
how do I do this did I say you do them
one after another because it's
fundamentally univariate yesterd serious
which is not the same thing not it
doesn't work like that Stephen okay but
do you intend it one day to look like
that yes probably but it requires more
investigation okay you know our series
and simple series that works out just
fine but beyond we need to go beyond
that or we won't have anything very
useful so that's horrible mess yeah I
mean it's not wrong but it's you know
it's not the most useful good case this
is like a power series about as simple
as things get no I understand that but
so what what does this now return in the
case where we're there so this is
returning an ordinary expression not a
series expression right right now yeah
go down into the scope examples and
there is a section for that okay all
right fine let me understand this
asymptotic solved so this is saying I
see this is restricting to reals
which is something you don't need to do
for any of these other ones yet right my
god that's exotic polynomial
equation with Hardy field coefficients
that's getting pretty exotic there well
yeah that's pretty wild
is that what we do also for the limit
case yes all six limit functions and
probably some of the essence other
asymptotic eyes yeah all the asymptotic
relations also do this since they're
defined in terms of upper limits and
lower limits sorry sorry sorry I spaced
for a second I got distracted by
something could you repeat that please
so all six of the limit functions right
because we have limit max limit min
limit and then we have three discrete
versions then we also have the 6s
emphatic relations which are defined in
terms of max limits and min limits so
all of those uniformly take this
direction option with the same values
for it yep okay um and with the same no
this multi-directional thing is new for
this isn't it nope it's in limit okay
because limit also okay so let me
understand the limits and tax okay so
the limit syntax looks like what the
limit syntax is not this syntax right is
that correct yeah it's X goes to
something where vector X goes to
something okay so that this so this will
be X Y goes to 0 0 for example right
okay right and then you could say right
if you wanted to come from like the top
right the first quality from above for
both of them so you'd say then direction
arrow
[Music]
I see for each one it will be say say
from above for example right okay so
that means used from above for all of
them and you can independently specify
for each variable if you want so let me
understand this again okay
yeah so what happens in fine minimum of
things we have multivariate what does
that do does it look like this again
syntax yeah so there are there are yes
you know but it if you don't you can do
because of history there is a sort of a
sequence of iterators or initial value
specs as well as the vector versions of
it okay okay so that so there's a
transpose version of this as well
right okay but are we recommending this
version what I want to do for twelve one
but we need more investigation is to
switch into an eros in text it's closer
to limit and make the order be you know
it be an option okay but that's why they
should remain experimental I know
because we need to know which order
piece the end here yes I want that to be
an option why because most important
thing is to get the first term and then
you optionally ask for more I see fair
enough
not sure it should be an option for me
and that's another way it's it's very
useful for a bunch of other things for
us to going forward because what we
don't want is asymptotic Laplace
transform asymptotic inverse Laplace
transform asymptotic Fourier transform
asymptotic inverse Fourier transform
there's gonna be a lot of them so that's
like 50 more functions to but we want a
wrapper it makes all of these well how
would that wrapper work kinda like
serious you know it's like like a future
series just about but so you're then
proposing that solve would have an
asymptotic wrapper or what these key
ones will have their own asymptotic you
know like these ones but for these like
integral and summation transforms the
primary way is that they should work
lightest wrapper just can you like you
wrap any round things but we won't have
the asymptotic Laplace transform
explicitly available ginseng yes that's
that's the basic idea
so so in other words the fella plants
one just evaluates be happy yes it
doesn't evaluate then you can try and
get an asymptotic evaluation just like
you can get a numerical evaluation right
where you make it inactive and you can
still run through there some type
although we've ended up with things like
and integrate and so on and then some I
guess I guess your claim is that that we
end up with an integrator and some but
we don't have endless transform yeah
exactly you know and we're following the
same thing here so we have we have n
solve we have you know n some we have n
integrate and n diesel and so yeah right
okay makes sense to me I mean and and
you know this implicitly implies that
for things like Laplace transform it's
not going to be the case that it spends
an hour trying to do the do some
symbolic form and then fails it's going
to be a fail fast type situation so that
was room right okay but integrators
to fail fast situation is it an
asymptotic integrate no integrate itself
no so it should be but it's it's as a
long history so it's you know maybe I
don't think it's obvious you can fail
fast I mean the whole thing problem is
hard to solve you know well it is I
don't understand how you could ever
guaranteed fail fast unless you can't
guarantee it but but you can structure
the solver in such a way that but that
you will fail fast yeah okay so at the
modern way that we structure solvers is
a little bit better at that right fair
enough okay so back to this so I suppose
I'm okay with this so long as you change
the examples and names because they're
really confusing to me at least yeah I I
agree that the examples are not as
polished as they should be and it's it's
on my to-do list clean them up before
release fine okay look I think if we can
change the variables change I think
it'll be okay I think it's
understandable fine
looks great should I look at anything
else here right now all kinds of
wonderful stuff
what the heck is that creature that's
that's a very that's a solution that's a
polynomial with lots of branches so
right each one of those lobes defines
two branches of a solution so you get
ten ten approximate solutions of that
intersection point well okay it was
pretty cool okay great all right let's
go on integrate Wow
okay a venerable function
there's no Derrick I have examples
Steven because you'll drown in the
examples in there okay what's new in
this page nothing go to a new reference
page yeah what okay that one is not
ready so okay look at the if you look at
these projects that's weird
probably it's probably because I'm not
running in the prototype here okay yes
why that's red it's because we have into
the future eyes the the documentation so
the build system doesn't know about it
yet so this previously had no generator
parameters parameters so to speak right
yeah that's nice okay
so that's the main changes generator
parameters thing so right yeah so look
at the second example where you have hey
you get not parameters but parametric
you know new functions three functions
yeah listen this generator parameters
thing we have a whole circus of these
things in this axiom axiomatic theory
and the ice-o-matic Theory repository
thing hmm which we need to sort out oops
we just crashed
what ok restart oh oh it's a new front
end so it's just a new front end yes
fresh well it is fresh oh um what do you
think I can do that should I look at
this and this is probably opened in
there that's what that one has a bunch
of graphics under it so to summarize
that's probably what I don't know if
it's gonna crash again or if oh ok this
book should report this because it's a
good thing for John just enabled by Erik
Stephen okay but you should tell us an
ugly graphic I know that's the
information but yes I agree it's ugly
really ugly
you
so we're generating up LF ones we avoid
doing app Elif once because appellate
one numeric behavior is not adequate so
what are we doing instead of app LF one
we not doing these you know there are a
lot of ones where there are sort of
larger right so you get like three
hypergeometric functions instead of one
app LS one so those you get that and in
fact in some cases you get much simpler
solutions in the parallel on and then
those that really absolutely do require
of EleFun we return on evaluated for now
why what is the story with app Elif one
I mean we've had that as a function for
like five years or something now
Devendra can speak to that of what the
problems worse that we found the problem
is that very simple examples didn't give
in
so you finally volume of a solid and it
might give back a really bad answer in
terms of LS one okay you described
there's the case where you need an app
LF one and the case where you can get
away without it yes okay so what I'm
caring about is the case where you look
at app Elif one is an exotic function if
you can get away without it get away
without it but the question is for
integrals were the only way to give a
result is using an appellate one what do
we do we don't I notice I'm asking
what's the problem with the appellate
one function that's what I asked of and
returns right so so when you have an
indifferent so indifferent diggers are
okay with a loved one if you have a
different ethel you need to work out
branch cuts need to work out
singularities you need to work out the
numeric so it just give me an example of
an integral that comes out isn't x to
the x an integral that involves a
telephone no - cause it's sine of sine
of x it's one of the one of the all-time
favorites and bobs on a pail of one
I mean do you know I mean okay my main
point is what you're saying is we get an
app Elif one it is a symbolic app Elif
one was still okay that's true okay so
the problem is that I mean there I can't
tell you exactly off the top of my head
since this was a couple of months ago
but I was able to construct relatively
simple examples where you know you
substitute in machine precision answers
and it returns on the valuated right and
even though I may have been technically
correct you know so what exactly is
going wrong inside of app EleFun that we
don't know I think I think that's a
question for Sasha or Oleg or someone
okay well let's ask it I mean I have a
question about a telephone in general I
mean so all their values were they're
simply not knowing or is it that we just
don't have efficient algorithms for it I
think that we didn't do a full job on
first of all that five of them we only
have one okay this F 1 to F 5 now so
these are multi very always busy well
yeah but but but so generally speaking
multivariate special functions I know
horrible right and and we're going to
start down that track seriously but not
right now and so Appel if one I think
they found enough of a special cases
that can be reduced to the functions we
actually do have but as tests now
indicate it wasn't adequate it doesn't
it not complete coverage and we don't
know exactly what it is it's its own
investigation to trace that down
but is there a defining series or
something for this creature yes it's
right in front of you on the telephone
page the sum of yeah if you yeah or if
you just open the details probably it
has
that series really defining it does it
globally define it define it but the
point would be that you have cameras
over the denominator except research
there is lots of exceptional cases yeah
I'm sorry you're saying that there are
things that blow up because there are
poor cameras where they're integers
which which you know give you
denominated zeros and so in a relation
be the numerator for cameras and
denominator for cameras and they might
main accuracy cancel the singularity
though they may not the same story the
hypergeometric 1 of 1 and things with
that but much worse and just to answer
your question if you go down to the
property relation of a same page you
will see an example of the integrals
which you talking about
so typically you have an an abstract
power of some polynomial like X plus 1
raised to n and that would lead to an
Appel
but it's really hard to figure out when
they should be given and then not I
don't understand why are you saying that
when they should be given as and when
there's an alternative to repeal of one
or what the thing is that the new
functionality sits on top of the old one
and for officiants we called before the
legacy integrate and there's moving a
first to figure out in advance that it's
giving the new functionality is giving
back in a pail of one yes but the all
the functionality might give back a sum
of three hubba geometric functions or
something because those hypergeometric
smites I - I get it but so I don't stand
why the algorithm isn't you run the new
stuff it gives in a telephone you say ok
let's put it on the shelf
yes you know let's keep going and see
whether they be old stuff gives
something great the old stuff fails and
says I can't integrate it at all pick
the Appel of one back off the shelf and
return it yes so if integrate with a
very modern function like some which was
written in 2007 you could do that the
current integrate is horrible because we
don't know how often let you try
something whatever that sounds
that's a different explanation okay that
that's a different thing what I thought
you were saying is that something is
wrong with returning the appellate one
because of the Devils the argument given
Stephen okay the reason we avoid it
right now
the new rules the Ruby means rule-based
integration okay yeah okay so the new
rules we excluded the rules that do emit
a pair left once initially we had them
with them I say we've now excluded them
yes and we lost our own for examples but
I think that's better to hold off until
we have a better understanding of
integrate it's a first and Stephen if
I'm if I'm a HS one the reason we turned
them off is because I went through all
of the examples or integrate and you
know some of these elementary examples
were returning things that were no
longer you know once you substituted in
values didn't work and that didn't that
was worse than returning it for abstract
things that you know we can't currently
do so you're saying it's better to
return an evaluated integrate that you
can evaluate numerically than to return
app LF one that blows up when you try
and evaluate it numerically this okay I
mean okay so let me just ask you with
respect to you know app lf1 what should
be involved in I mean I don't quite
understand is this something where for
example you know the coming attraction
of function evaluation is surely machine
learning stuff well we basically you
know just like you know 30 years ago we
started using these economized rational
approximations that other people hadn't
used for function evaluation I think the
coming attraction is using you know
known that type stuff for that and I
doubt that Stephen why I don't know how
you get I mean there's a lot of
Technology it needs to be developed to
control the precision in that it's it's
not like data science it's it's it needs
to have you know needs to be correct
sure but I mean the question is you
what the obvious thing to try to do is
to try to learn one of these things and
their night we could try it out but I
just very much doubt that that's gonna
work very much because all the machine
learning stuff is built for something
that's super approximate it's good at
dealing with very fuzzy and things and
still be able to get it quantitative
high precision answer is is a bizarre
for modern machine learning exactly and
machine learning is about reducing a
large number of things to a small number
of things whereas here there really
isn't a natural way to it depends how
exotic the function is I mean it look
what it might be useful for it's getting
initial approximations if there's a way
to tighten the approximations up if
there is right okay about the Train that
we would first need to know what they
should evaluate to ensure does anybody
know all the tables of a plus one that
anybody ever computed or is it kind of
you know wild
telephone at all and I think that if you
honest once you finish this current coin
project will go up LF one that would be
the what is the what is the genealogy of
coin vs. Appel f1 and it's sort of the
next level of number of singularities
beyond hyper geometric sand Meyers and
so on I said so that that sort of pretty
much covers the second-order
differential equations are these yes so
what what is the Appel f1 is it a
solution of an OD no PPD is there to a
that's a all right what kind of PD is it
linear PDE to what most of them are or
you know linear PDE s or systems of PDE
s like the horn system is one very
classic case of system of hypergeometric
PDS okay alright let's go on cool so
okay same constants of integration deal
what is this should be interesting
listen the other one but let me not
worry about that okay so what are we
seeing here so this is this is
improvements to dissolve okay yes and
that to two projects effectively one is
that currently dissolve often spends an
inordinate amount of time trying to
evaluate an integral and often fails gee
I get the idea I got the idea so you're
just reducing you're unraveling the OD
ease into something which just has
integrals get back one good solution
like e to the power X and there example
over there the other solution is
impossible to compute basically so we
decide when to give up and then don't
know I understand I understand so the
issue is so right now you've got method
and active integrals which well that's
not it's automatic Stephen it's it was
just need to be tested not tested and it
all looks good yeah so so you're saying
you can predict when the integral you
generate will not actually be valuable
yes if you look at the output it's
essentially an indefinite integral
nothing more it's 1 to X so we try in
different digression from integrate if
that fails they give up and the worst
that could happen is that someone wants
integral to evaluate this to a next week
and they can be forever so wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute so
you are returning I mean this is the
first time we've ever returned
explicitly inactivated things
no we haven't any sort for a PT's PD
solutions return also inactive sums
right and my RG reduce returns and
activated
things nobody will ever figure out what
to do here
unless we have some visual indication
and some mouse-over nobody is ever going
to figure out they're gonna say what do
I do with that integral I want to you
know I mean in other words if I fill in
let's say the integral has a bunch of
symbolic parameters and it can't be
evaluated symbolically given those
arbitrary symbolic parameters but if
they were to go in and specify those
things you know then it could evaluate
making sense yes so but that won't work
if the thing is actually explicitly and
activated right I don't care people are
not going to figure it out what do you
mean if you're if you that first one is
not inactivated which is the point if
you hover over the second one there's
there's a tooltip it's telling you it's
an inactive integral okay that's helps I
don't particularly like that tooltip but
it helps that says that people are not
going to figure out I mean we should
expand that tooltip to say something
clearer and better I think we couldn't
but so my question is when we do this
gosh this is a mess this is common oh no
it's not a mess well it's complicated
well if you substitute into this okay if
you substitute that solution in it will
actually do the right thing if you take
derivative of that it will work right I
understand if you take a parametric
derivative of that thing that will work
if you expect the thing if you
substitute x equals three there or
something it definitely won't work
oh it's substitute let's imagine I even
substitute x equals one where that
integral that should be zero right it's
definitely not going to do that
correctly because it's inactivated you
need to activate it yeah I understand I
understand so what I'm saying is when
you substitute in there people might
have thought if it was just an ordinary
integrate that was unavailable
see what I'm saying then I mean like for
example if I do an integral here if I
say I know how to do this and have it
you know sine of sine of X comma X okay
that will be unavailing it actually if I
say sine of sine of X a X a B here
actually that may be more accurate x0b
right that will be unavailable if I say
that arrow B arrow pi right that will
evaluate right but nothing like this
will work for these inactivated
integrals right okay so that's that's
what you will get back an inactive
integral if you you'll see it trim say I
understand I understand which you won't
know why that happened so to speak I
mean so what you'll see then if I do
this if I say inactivate okay great I
have an inactivated integral it's nice
that this is now why aren't these in
lighter colors when they're inactivated
because only the integral isn't
activated so really you should have put
a connor oh I see I see Instagram she
this helps me this helps me because that
this is okay so I don't even know why
the whole expression is Mouse is mouse
over 2 which is although it's good but I
see that that integral sign there is
grass is brown yes which is good so this
is really an activated so active often
do great yes exactly
okay so now if I say they're obviously
BR oppai oops
no yeah obviously it's not gonna work
yes
you know look I think we should improve
that tooltip and say something more
useful I think so too
like what I mean that would be extremely
non-standard well it just needs to say
use activate that's extremely
non-standard and for what well for
tooltips in general and you know we have
a bunch of right every inactivated thing
has a tooltip which is just inactive I
know but maybe we should I mean I'm not
sure where they should all have a you
know an instruction set you know
instructions with them I just think that
thing is very you know it's very austere
to just say that I think we should look
at the design that let's look at some
examples of inactivated things and let's
try and come up with a plusher design
for that tooltip I mean right now it
isn't designed it's just a plain text
tooltip um all right
so you see then we get a huge
performance improvement like factor of
two is this small change well I'm sure
we do in there and I mean I'm sure we do
because we're doing less I mean you're
saying but under are there integrals
where you where you would try and if you
put the effort in you would succeed or
are these integrals where you know up
front it's impossible I know up front
because I mean frankly I've got your
experience and looking at these and I
know that there's zero chance of ability
and integral with so to speak definite
integral methods when it's already
freely indefinite integral mechanism now
if it's piecewise we don't know what to
go through so there are judiciously
allow it to go through but typically it
never helps to try and evaluate an
integral beyond a point
and you know fraction of a second listen
are you know I'm gonna have to leave in
a moment here but but let me just scan
ahead for this I I would like to come
back to this I feel I feel like this
requires a bit more discussion this you
know returning inactivated things sure I
think could you just scan through the
rest of its yeah let's let's just take a
look what else look at that benchmark I
think that has son so part of what we've
been doing we haven't been going back to
this part of dissolve this is both of
these things they in active integrals
and systematics are working through
you're saying that that if you leave
them with if you allow inactive
integrals and you consider that a
solution um the UM and you consider that
a solution then rather ugly and what
happened to this notification but mean
leaf counts okay cool I mean okay you
know say you now count as a success yes
exactly
okay fine so you changed a little bit um
we change the game a little bit yeah
yeah right so this is now a completely
different thing here this is a reduce
okay so these are recognizing dependent
structure or independent structure to
get you know a big performance gain and
what's the hood yeah okay well it's
wonderful but what's the matter method
for I mean like there could be six two
thousand six thousand different kinds of
structures you could look for yeah well
this is what's called you know so if you
have an equation often when you're a big
equations they don't all involve all
variables they involve some sure and you
can structure them if
very lucky you actually have sort of an
into independent systems of indications
and you should solve them independently
because they they complex the
algorithmic complexity is more than
linear so if you can split it to solve
two smaller problems you've a big gain
and in this case the worst case
complexity is exponential with doubly
exponential so it's a huge gain mm-hmm
the other way you can do it is if you
have what's called block triangular
structure sure which means that that
there's some equations that let's say it
only depends on on Y Z and one that
depends on X Y Z if you solve no if you
solve those fewer variables first then
then you you substitute back and and you
have again smaller problems to solve all
right but anyway the basic bottom line
is whatever it is that we're doing for
structure probing it's not it's going to
scale okay we're not going to get
something whether you know probe no no
this is this is super fast it's in in
below a millisecond um good okay let me
just have a very very very quick look
here oops let me let me look at this do
I have to look at this in the prototype
branch yes
I saw well it died so you like it to
close the graphics sections I think it
would open correctly I think there's a
graphics it's I'm guessing it's a
graphics that's problematic in the new
front-end and there's another one that
he'll say I don't know what graphics is
problematic but let's say this new
there's a general bug with you know not
quite correct
non-canonical graphics crashing the
front end so that may be wonderful would
you like me to share I can I mean I
don't have that notebook handy but I can
certainly illustrate those two functions
super quickly all right because I'm
gonna run off here um yeah I gotta run -
I'm in deep trouble okay so the new C
type setting you've already seen it's a
little like you know it just says C so
you know that this is you know capital C
and not some strange character and then
see if one maybe the tooltip should have
the whole thing I think that would be
clearer especially given that the yeah
we can do that okay right okay next
right so if I do route to the seventh
that's exciting what I'm seeing on your
screen with screen tourism that vector
less is cool optimization side
and I hope they take this in credit I
forgot the plus one there we go so in
the past you would get basically
something that looked like what I just
typed in now you get a little icon
telling you I don't especially like the
I like the concept here I don't like the
particular form because it looks to me
like it's square root of minus Oh point
seven nine seven hey see what I'm saying
I I don't think that quite works it it's
an indication that it's a it's a root
object well maybe it should come after
maybe the root thing should come after
the number five just doesn't it just
doesn't look right to have that square
root thing or there's got to be some
other way of doing it this isn't quite
right otherwise it just looks way too
much like square root of that thing okay
um all right listen I have to run what
do we do from here on out let's let's
schedule another one of these probably
it can be done in half an hour maybe we
can combine it with something else but
it's actually not count on that let's
let's get a full hour and let's also
have available through some design folk
to look at some of these things like
plusher indefinite you know inactivated
tooltips and so on okay okay and then we
should be able to nail it is that
automatically scheduled or should we
request it I think you have to request
it
I'm dr. Ellen okay all right under the
live stream um thanks guys see you later